la pilules contre l'impuissance
masculine déjà commercialisé aux états
unis va débarquer sur le marché européen
par semaine en sortir en france le
viagra 75 pour la pilule pas remboursés
par la sécurité sociale est uniquement
sur prescription médicale
15 octobre 1998 le viagra est
officiellement commercialisé en france
une petite pilule bleue contre
l'impuissance masculine n'est par hasard
quelques années plus tôt dans le
laboratoire américain pfizer
c'est en testant une molécule dont on
espérait qu'elle fut efficace dans le
traitement des angines de poitrine qu'on
s'est aperçu des effets secondaires pour
le moins inattendu les patients étaient
pris de soudaines érection le viagra eni
et dès son arrivée dans les pharmacies
américaines le succès est immédiat
on n'a jamais vu autant de gens se
réveillent sur un médicament comme c'est
le cas depuis les dernières semaines
ça a pris de telles proportions qu'on
dirait que tout le monde il promesse de
virilité qui séduira aussi très vite les
français alors si c'est pour donner un
plus pourquoi pas trois mois après le
début de la commercialisation du viagra
plus de 200 mille patients s'étaient vu
prescrire le médicament
une réussite qui dépasse les espérances
des scientifiques du laboratoire pfizer
a reçu des lettres de malades ils ont
dit merci des gens qui avaient dans le
mariage avait été brisée et perdu leur
et pousse des gens qu'il peut avoir de
pas avoir de relation avec une personne
sexe opposé en raison de leur premier
médicale dix ans plus tard cet homme de
83 ans disait aussi merci au viagra
le médicament avait changé sa vie sans
lui à grand jeu n'aurait peut-être pas
pu
continuer aussi longtemps une activité
qui est extrêmement important comme le
disait et qui importe au coeur à ma
femme que moi même je dirais peut-être
plus maintenant ma femme comment
en 20 ans 65 millions d'ordonnancés de
diagrammes ont été prescrites dans l'eau
[Musique]